il ya quelque chose que j'ai en moi
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un souvenir
souvenir
les souvenirs de ce que vous avez fait
n'importe qui peuvent la fable ouf
dimanche air à 5 millions de livres il
suffit d'un peu de muscle
[Musique]
mais aucune oeuvre d'art ne vaut une vie
humaine avec toi tout de suite
à
hop une oeuvre d'art nous vaut une vie
humaine
[Musique]
ou est ce que les je me rappelle pas
simple sur la tête
[Musique]
ça fera du bien
est-ce qu'ils avaient déjà été utilisés
quoi qu'il est dans la tête le couvrir
maintenant c'est mon détendez vous et on
leur fait faire croire ça fait partie de
votre blanc vous êtes complices tous les
deux cll que l'a suggéré
tu crois pas ton histoire pourquoi tu
m'as menti
venir est enfermé dans une cage
avec suffisamment de force
le verrou a sauté
il faut que je te dise quelque chose
[Musique]
il est prête
je me rappelle de tout